el último de una serie de juicios contra
destacados críticos de beijing
jimmy lai el magnate de la prensa hong
kong esa creador de apple daily y
activista prodemocracia fue acusado este
jueves de fraude y permanecerá en
prisión preventiva hasta que la corte
dice una sentencia en abril de 2021 en
medio de una creciente represión contra
la disidencia la hay una de las voces
más fuertes a favor de la democracia
para el territorio semiautónomo se suma
a la lista de arrestos y condenas el
miércoles joshua wong admitió e iván lan
fueron encarcelados por su activismo
queridos lectores es un día
particularmente utilicen los 25 años de
historia de nuestro periódico
enfrentando la represión nuestro
fundador jimmy lai seguirá bajo custodia
hasta abril del próximo año la ied de 71
años junto con otros dos ejecutivos
están acusados de defraudar a una
empresa gubernamental al incumplir un
acuerdo de alquiler de terrenos con las
oficinas de su periódico el pasado
agosto la policía hizo una redada en la
sede del tabloide por sospecha de
colusión con fuerzas extranjeras un
delito que con la nueva ley de seguridad
nacional de china podría castigarse con
hasta cadena perpetua además se les
acusó de su
para grupos activistas prodemocráticos
en ese entonces las autoridades le
concedieron la libertad tras el pago de
una fianza 40 horas después docenas de
activistas prodemocracia y opositores
han sido arrestados bajo la polémica
norma china que puso fin a las masivas
movilizaciones en la es colonia y según
los críticos podría acabar con el futuro
del movimiento prodemocrático hong kong
et